questions right here what do you I got
no idea I don't know I need a
thing that no word that coming back to
be is fun people having fun seeing it so
you know that I guess that's the best
compliment you together for filming I
never got that one before hi was always
like intellectual Requiem was heroin
fountain was mysterious the rest of it
was sad this one was fun but worked out
right here if you do a big budget and
Hobbit folks to do believe we missed
comic you colonel
will I company in the metro area which
is coming as well if it's as cold as it
is today you know I you know I love the
steroids I didn't come here with the
mountain no we were 32 million dollars i
was happy i think under 20 so you may
hopefully i'll have a career where I can
come back and forth
right
very strong and sexy
honey
right right right I guess I'm with a
good student I'll be back here
hey congratulations your reward whenever
I see a movie of yours I always think
that the characters are really really
well casted how do you cost people act
Ricky war or Mickey Rourke and Natalie
Portman how do you test them out well
Natalie I thought about for this movie
10 years ago and Mickey really have been
getting as well and then I worked with a
great casting director marriage renew
and then I producer stuff retinas were
just one has great passing instincts it
was his idea for Marlon Wayans in that a
record for dream I thought that was a
crazy idea
and it worked out really well so I just
listened to a lot of people and I think
about it I just spent a lot of time
thinking about it it's actually pretty
hard to get there and it's not instant
this is a lot of work right here
in the back
a husband
y'all
these are for
a perfect exactly you know I think you
know independence is when you're kind of
independent on the financial you know
the financial realities you know so that
you know I think it's a very hard word
to describe and people can try and
figure it out the years but it's
basically when filmmakers are in control
of the movie as opposed to the people
catch it striving to make
he will be running up to give you money
go out darrell's right I mean half of
the wrestler we thought it was going to
get into here and this film was just as
hard and I'm sure the next one will be
just as hard it's just you know I think
any times try to do anything that's not
in the box they count is it hard to go
from ballet to Wolverine to and what can
we expect from that film I don't know
what will ring to is no
producers are my pet employed legend
light to the beach Ryan all over the guy
without a jacket and you write an art
final exit harbor
right here you dare you
I just went what would it be
run down your honor
take the world with yours
I'd say one award would be Colombo v12
two words epic poem I think that sums up
the whole dirt Awards this year but
their methods for pharmacists impressed
all over the world surprised everyone
what's your covert attractive
what she thought you
it's a good question oh that you don't
have to be insane to be a good actor you
can even be nice unusual but yes I
understand as a fellow evolved in
editing more visual effects concepts
were added to Adam
references and crazy things
what does that do to you guys in coast
in terms of
finances on
it made it really easy no we you know we
kind of just you know we have a great
visual effects team that
review and
they understood what we were doing
and a box of Sun
when it came to know we came to some
spending too much money on Tuesday
not only that but they had I think they
worked i don't know if they work 24
hours but they certainly worked the
whole time I'm trying to get the movie
ready for this and I don't think anybody
expected all of this to happen so if
they did they knew a lot more than any
one of us standing here according to a
celestion say that again he fed about
the exhaust cutouts I think you look I
think there's a lot of great films this
year I mean I was I fought against the
idea that mean 10 films you know I
thought having haven't been around for a
long time and having you know had five
films and trying to win that but I must
say each year I see better more
interesting films i think this year more
so than i can remember in a long time
and you know this is an example of some
that without Darren and without that
shot everybody else I would have been
impossible you know it's just so the
chances are as good as anybody else
thank you